Hey, have you been on Twitter during the
last weeks? Or were you on Holidays, like me?
Because if you were on Twitter, there is
zero chance that you weren’t hit by somebody
posting about Stable Diffusion,
just look at all of this!!
What is Stable Diffusion,
you ask from your hammock?
Well, Stable Diffusion is an
open-source alternative to DALL-E 2.
So unlike DALL-E 2, which is
hidden behind an API and a paywall,
Stable Diffusion is a text-to-image generator
like DALL-E that has open-sourced its code,
then the weights for academic purposes,
and as of very recently, it has even
released the model weights for everyone!
Today, we explain Latent Diffusion Models which is
the algorithm that stands behind Stable Diffusion.
And Latent Diffusion Models, or short LDMs,
are a special kind of the more general class
of diffusion models about which you
may or may not have heard already.
So, if you are interested in how Stable Diffusion
works, this might be just the right video for you!
But before we dive into the explanations, let’s
thank AssemblyAI for sponsoring today’s video!
Do you know that feeling when you
have hours and hours of audio data
lying around and you want to
transcribe it – automatically?
Yes, I do know that feeling,
especially because I do not want to enter
the captions manually for every video I do.
Luckily AssemblyAI, can help me transcribe my
audio with state-of-the-art APIs
for automatic speech recognition!
And you can use their APIs too, to
automatically convert recorded audio.
But wait, there is more! You
can even transcribe in real-time
live audio streams into text, which can come
in handy for conferences or other live streams.
And believe me that AssemblyAIs models do not stop
there: it can even help you understand your audio
data, for example it can summarize the content
and detect the topic of what is being said.
Or it can automatically tag bad words,
if one happens to slip out. So, what are
you waiting for, check out AssemblyAI
with the link in the description below!
I for example, used AssemblyAI to
transcribe my speech for this spot,
and you can see in the subtitles how well
it works. And think about it, I am quite a
hard example for speech transcription,
with my Eastern European accent. ;)
Now back to the video! First, let’s
recap what diffusion models are.
For more details for example on classifier-free
guidance, do check out our previous videos on
this. But, as far as our explanations
of diffusion models in general go,
this video has the technically
most correct version, because
we cleared up a confusion that Ms.
Coffee Bean had this whole time.
But let’s not get ahead of ourselves and
talk about diffusion models first! The
diffusion process is where you diffuse
more and more noise into your image.
So, you take an image, and in t steps,
you gradually add more noise to it,
until at the last timestep t, the
image is approximately just noise.
Diffusion models go in the opposite direction,
in other words, they learn to
reverse the diffusion process.
When we are trying to generate
an image with a diffusion model,
we follow each of these t steps and
reduce the noise gradually, step by step.
For this, we use the same neural network,
so just one neural network, usually a U-Net,
to go from step t to step t-1 and here,
for visualization purposes we have chosen
step t to be a noisy dog and step t-1
to be a less noisy version of the dog.
Short sidenote on U-Nets: A UNet is a
convolution-based neural network that is
downsampling an image into a lower dimensional
representation and reconstructs it during
upsampling. The downsampling and upsampling stacks
of layers communicate through skip connections.
And now, what exactly is the
input to the neural network?
It’s an image at step t and the neural
network’s output is the total noise
that should be subtracted from the
noisy version of the image at step t
to reconstruct the original image,
so the clear picture of the dog.
Wait, let’s untangle this a bit and
recapitulate the whole diffusion thing
from the beginning because it is an important
detail Ms. Coffee Bean got wrong so far
(of course, I knew the
correct version all the time).
Unfortunately, the papers are not so clear about
it. How it is done becomes clear from the code.
The diffusion process is all about going from
a little noise to more noise. The backward
diffusion process is the reverse, and this is
what we do with the help of diffusion models.
And the diffusion model itself, so this
one U-Net that we apply at each step,
gets a noisy image at step t and predicts
the whole noise that the image contains,
and not just the noise we need
to subtract to get from t to t-1.
It’s just that we do not trust the model enough
to just subtract this whole noise in one go,
so at each step, we extract just a fraction of
the total noise from the image at timestep t.
Reasons for going step by step is
that we break down a hard problem,
of generating an image from just noise,
into t steps, where each step can correct and
improve upon the previous one, especially when
the whole time we are trying to inject textual
information when doing text-to-image generation.
It's easier to inject textual
information gradually than all at once.
Ok, so this was basically an
erratum to our previous videos,
where we thought that at each step, the
model predicts only a fraction of the noise.
But actually, the diffusion model predicts
the total amount of noise from which we
then subtract only a fraction to give it
afterwards yet another go at denoising.
But now, how does the text come into play? It
is injected into the whole process in two ways:
First as input to the diffusion
model by concatenating the text
representation coming from a language
transformer to the image input.
And second, through cross-attention, letting the
U-Net attention layers attend to the text tokens.
Now, what about Stable Diffusion,
and how does this work?
The idea behind stable diffusion was
introduced in this CVPR paper called
“High-Resolution Image Synthesis
with Latent Diffusion Models”
from Heidelberg folk [proud]
who now moved to Munich [sad].
The authors proposed latent diffusion models,
or short LDMs, to address a
shortcoming of diffusion models:
When trying to generate a large image,
such as a 1024 x 1024 image,
then the U-Net in here, would have to take
in a 1024 x 1024-dimensional noise grid
and produce an image out of it.
As you can imagine, this can become
really expensive for one diffusion step
and one has to do it t times,
where t can be something like 150.
What people did so far to circumvent
this high dimensionality problem,
as we have seen in the GLIDE paper for example,
is that they actually train their diffusion
model on much smaller images, like 256 x 256
and then have an extra neural network
that learned to upsample and sharpen
256 x 256 to higher resolution, for
example. And this is one way to do it.
But LDMs take another approach.
The core concept of LDMs is to
surrender the idea of working in the image
space and work on a latent space instead.
You may think of it as of an autoencoder
encompassing the diffusion model, as follows:
For diffusion models, we had the original
image to which we added more and more noise.
But now, we do not work with the image itself,
but with a lower-dimensional representation of it,
because we take the image and run it through
an encoder, which is basically a VQGAN.
This encoder also has a decoder
to reconstruct the image.
This encoder and decoder
are trained together first,
to encode the image into a lower dimensional
space and then reconstruct the image from it.
Now, instead of applying noise onto
the image for the diffusion step,
we apply noise onto the lower-dimensional
representation of the data.
And for the backward diffusion, the
U-Net works with this representation
instead of the whole image. Since the
image representation is lower dimensional,
the U-Net does not have a
lot of heavy lifting to do.
Even more, by compressing the image first
through the encoder, the encoder decoder can
take care of image details and let the diffusion
model focus on the important image semantics.
This makes LDMs much faster than usual
diffusion models, so this enables us to run
Stable Diffusion on laptop hardware, instead
of clusters or you know, OpenAI servers! 😉
We hope you see how clever, but similar
LDMs are to what previous work like GLIDE
did: GLIDE, took an image, downsampled
it from let’s say, 1024 x 1024 pixels
to 256 x 256 resolution with a usual image
downsampling algorithm, staying in image space.
Then they ran diffusion and upsampled the
result to get a high-resolution image.
Now with LDMs, instead of a standard downsampling
algorithm that produces low-resolution images,
the LDM encoder takes a high-resolution image
and embeds it into a compressed code of its own,
that captures the semantics of the
image, but in a space that does
not look to us like the original image anymore.
And the diffusion model can take it from there.
As you can see from the paper, the author’s
initial work on LDMs was producing images
of human faces and objects. This is because
the model whose output we see in Figure 1,
was trained on human faces and objects.
And you know, what kind of data comes into the
diffusion model, this is what they also produce.
What makes Stable Diffusion so special and fit
for art generation, is that it was actually an LDM
trained on a core dataset consisting of, we cite
“LAION-Aesthetics, a soon to be released subset of
LAION 5B. LAION-Aesthetics was created with a new
CLIP-based model that filtered LAION-5B based on
how “beautiful” an image was, building on ratings
from the alpha testers of Stable Diffusion”.
And this different training data makes
it have its own style that is different
from other text-to-image generators
like DALL-E 2, Midjourney or Imagen.
So to sum up: what is now Stable Diffusion?
It is basically the work that follows
the Latent Diffusion Models paper,
where authors of the paper teamed with StabilityAI
and communities such as Eleuther AI and LAION.
Now, with Stable Diffusion we have an
image generator tuned to produce art,
as it was trained on “beautiful” images,
which were often produced by human artists.
It will be interesting to see what kind of new
copyright law these AI generations will spawn.
Some artists feel bad to see that AI can now
do something in seconds that took them hours
to make. But other artists consider the AI to be
a sort of tool, which still needs human input.
And the human hours that go into diffusion-based
image generation is not a neglectable amount.
Just think about the hours one can spend
in tuning the text prompt and waiting for
the right result to come out, only to notice
that the astronaut is riding the horse again,
when I actually wanted the horse
riding the astronaut on the moon!
If you are interested in using Stable Diffusion
yourself, then check out the diffusers library
or any other helpful tutorials out there.
It’s really amazing what the community
has put out in such a short amount of time
in terms of documentation and
in terms of generations.
Just look at this Twitter user bringing
their 4 year-old’s sketches to life.
Wow. Do you think this is creativity?
We’re so curious to know what you think about this
so, we’ll be watching the comment section closely.
Ms. Coffee Bean, it is time to say
goodbye. See you in the next video!
Okay, bye!